all right on top of the mlb moving out
of the all-star game out of atlanta
dozens of craven ceos have jumped onto
the left's trash
georgia bandwagon to me it's shameful
but what if it became the new normal we
just accepted
jp morgan's ceo jamie dimon wants
corporate america to get
more involved in politics writing this
today companies like ours
have an extraordinary capability to help
to not just with funding but with
developing strong
public policy oh really jp morgan's
going to run the country which could
have a greater impact on society
here to react is dan crenshaw dan stand
down as congressman from texas
jamie dimon is going to start making
decisions isn't that a relief
yeah look you know he should run for
congress if he really wants to be in
politics and that's my message to all of
these
ceos and i don't think what they i don't
think they understand how damaging
their entry into politics is for for far
too long already americans are forced to
you know watch a different late night
comedy show every time they watch a
movie they have to
deal with the fact that the actor they
might be watching doesn't like them
thinks that their ideas are stupid and
now we have to look at products or our
banks or
our airlines and think to ourselves well
yeah i want to buy this product or
purchase this ticket but these people
hate me
or they don't think my ideas are good or
they lie about my ideas they lie about
what we want to do for election
integrity
this is damaging our culture it's
damaging our social fabric they're doing
far more damage than they realize
absolutely listen uh corporate america
wants to get involved
and they want to play a role because
they want to look out for their own
interests when they start controlling
the policy of trying to win over
politicians by changing
their corporate structure and their
corporate policy i think it gets a
little dangerous they already have big
tech
and they're already grabbing wall street
wall street's saying take me i'm yours
i want to change gears and get your
opinion on this because you tweeted
something about it
united airlines wants to get a little
bit more woke they want to go out and
say
that 50 of their the new hires from here
on in are going to be women or people
of color united airlines is officially
stating this they're planning to train 5
000 new pilots and a new pilot training
program by 2030
of which at least half will be women uh
and people of color
what do you think about this idea
look i think just about every passenger
that gets on a plane thinks to themself
i hope the pilot is qualified and can
take off and land the plane
safely look if they want a virtue signal
that's fine
you know what really pissed me off about
united was the way they lied about
the election integrity reforms that
we're trying to make in places like
georgia and texas
they lied about it they insinuated that
these that these were
voter suppression laws and of course
that's not true clearly they didn't read
it and again
they're venturing into territory that
they don't understand um
that they that they don't know that they
know nothing about um
and in an attempt to what this is what i
call the phenomenon that that's going on
it's it's progressive fascism because
because what is fascism
well it's the it's the it's the
regimentation of the economy
of society and it's the forced
suppression of
of your opposition that's what's
happening right now
the democrats have successfully um
captivated the institutions you know pop
culture
hollywood our education institutions and
now our corporations into their own woke
agenda
this is fascism right and they use
cancel culture
as a tool to impose their fascism on us
and so they're always using this ain't
these anti this anti-fascist labeling
against the right but they're the ones
who actually engage in the tactics and
it's time we expose that
that's really what's happening here and
we should see it for what it is look if
they've if they want to if they want to
hire based on quotas
and virtue signal to us and imply that
that people didn't have these
opportunities to begin with
fine but don't lie about other policy
okay
that's what i really have a problem with
if republicans don't unite understand
what you
said is actually fact not opinion uh
they're gonna get steamrolled and lose
everything
uh they did not have a bad election day
you did not have a bad election day
you lost the presidency uh but you
almost took back the house
and by all legitimate purposes you
almost defied logic and held on to the
senate
uh except for what happened on uh in
january
um so uh it's time it's a wake-up call
uh you've been
being on a lot of different levels we'll
see what's gonna happen to the ballot
box
uh dan crenshaw thanks so much
appreciate you scrambling for us today